[Applause]  under 3 20 to go in regulation and  that's by four with the ball  kyrie irving for three kyrie irving  keeps his big night going kyrie irving  sizing things up  jaylen brown on him it just kyrie irving  sizing things up jaylen brown on him it  just  steps into that with rhythm  and you can see that brown is hanging  back gives him enough room  which allowed for smart to be able to  contest that shot there at the end of  the clock  there's a steal by harris pick the  pocket of jason tatum  huge boston turnover now kyrie irving  squares up and then i'm not sure how in  transition the celtics have left kyrie  open kyrie irving open this  often from the three-point line  remaining this was a two-point game  after one quarter boston led by six  brooklyn